economía en france 24 saludo a mi
compañera en el estudio de daniela
blandón daniela muy buenas noches vamos
a comenzar hablando de méxico en este
país aumentó la cantidad de remesas a
pesar de la pandemia hola santiago pues
cuando inició la crisis se pensaba que
estos envíos que hacen los ciudadanos en
el exterior y van a caer drásticamente
sin embargo lograron no sólo crecer en
más del 11 por ciento en méxico sino que
alcanzaron un máximo histórico del más
del 40 mil millones de dólares esta es
la segunda fuente de divisas de méxico
después de las exportaciones
automotrices pero no sólo ha crecido el
número de operaciones que pasó de 111 a
119 millones el año pasado sino que
también subió el promedio de cada
operación alrededor de 340 dólares la
mayoría de estos envíos proviene de eeuu
en donde hoy se estima que reside en
unos 38 millones de mexicanos hablemos
ahora de la economía de la unión europea
que borró siete años de crecimiento
constante al menos eso es lo que dice en
la oficina de estadística que él
ducto interno bruto promedio del bloque
comunitario se desplomó un 6 4 por
ciento en 2020 esta es la primera vez
desde 2013 que el crecimiento es
negativo aunque está por debajo de lo
que se había estimado no todo es malo y
aunque no hay un consolidado con los 27
países que conforman la unión europea
los más afectados y han ido revelando
sus datos de manera individual españa
por ejemplo recibió el golpe más duro
con una contracción del 11 por ciento
seguida de italia y de francia alemania
ha sido hasta el momento el mejor
librado con un descenso de su producción
de bienes y servicios del 5 por ciento y
pasamos ahora de noticias corporativas
jeff bezos dejará su cargo como sitio de
amazon pues el gigante del comercio
electrónico hizo dos anuncios 8 por un
lado que facturó 38 por ciento más en
2020 y que duplicó sus ganancias hasta
más de 21.000 millones de dólares y por
otro que es un fundador jefe de pesos
quien se pelea el puesto con hilo en más
que como el hombre más rico del mundo
de ser sus hijos y pasar a ser su
presidente ejecutivo en este puesto será
reemplazado a partir del tercer
trimestre por andy jazzy quien es el
actual y muy veterano jefe del servicio
de computación en la nube que es el más
rentable de la compañía pero esos no se
va a ir de la empresa dijo no yo acá me
quedo por el contrario de lo que va a
hacer es que va a pasar a hacer el
presidente ejecutivo que al fin de
cuentas viene siendo casi lo mismo andy
jazzy será la cara visible de santiago y
diez besos tendrá más tiempo para
dedicarse a sus otros negocios pero a
seguir teniendo el mismo poder de
decisión que tiene hoy movimientos
corporativos daniel hablemos ahora de
tesla que llamará a miles de sus
automóviles a revisión mir el fabricante
de automóviles eléctricos de lujo cuyo
dueño es el excéntrico y muy popular
también millonario y lo en más que
llamar a revisión un total de 135 mil
vehículos de los modelos s y x la
administración nacional para la
seguridad en la carretera de eeuu
y detectó problemas en las pantallas
táctiles de los vehículos que pueden
provocar un aumento del riesgo de
accidente lo que esta entidad encontró
específicamente es que hay fallas que
provocan la pérdida de la cámara de
visión trasera de los autos pero además
puede causar también la pérdida de los
controles para desempañar el parabrisas
esto último afecta directamente los
sistemas de ayuda como por ejemplo el
piloto automático hasta el momento se ha
detectado este problema en más del 30
por ciento de los vehículos y
sorpréndase santiago con la respuesta de
tesla dice que esto no afecta a la
seguridad porque el conductor puede
perfectamente usar los espejos
retrovisores y limpiar el parabrisas de
manera manual
también se puede indicadores bueno en un
wall street parece diluirse el fenómeno
gamestop sus principales índices
cerraron con muy buenas ganancias por
segundo día las bolsas europeas
entretanto subieron gracias a una
aparente mejor panorama económico y las
bolsas de américa latina también se
contagiaron de ese optimismo y cerrar
una lanza
la cifra el día para el cierre de la
sección de una aldea es cuánto le gusta
la cerveza santiago 10 500 millones de
litros de cerveza eso dejó de producir
en 2020 alemania el país que acoge el
famoso oktoberfest las ventas fueron de
8 mil 700 millones de litros y cayeron
55 por ciento una cifra inédita desde la
posguerra a consumir más nos vendría
bien una cerveza fría ahora daniela
muchas gracias por esta información
gracias a ustedes por la sintonía siga
con nosotros buenas noches
[Música]
i